it was a long tiresome probe often
hobbled by all the dangers faced by the
investigators on the ground but finally
we have a more than a hundred page long
report carefully unweaving the facts not
to point the finger of blame but to
establish what happened the verdict
chlorine the banned chemical substance
was used in Duma
amid Moscow's warnings of an impeding
toxic provocation by anti-government
forces militant groups in eastern Goethe
are preparing a provocation with the use
of chemical weapons to blame the Syrian
government for a chemical attack Western
nations will use civilian casualties to
accuse the Syrian leadership of using
chemical weapons against its own people
again it wasn't the opcw's job to assign
blame so they didn't an important nuance
since both the government forces as well
as their enemy had the capability to use
chlorine the government on one hand and
al-nusra which is an organization
declared terrorist by the Security
Council are having the capability to
produce weaponized chlorine the report
details the course of the probe the
investigators talked to many who
witnessed the aftermath of the attack
and in particular these events at the
local hospital that were sold to the
world as the gruesome truth about the
incident the area was being heavily
bombarded at the time amid the ongoing
clashes so the medical facility was
indeed packed yet according to what the
OPCW learned the footage that circulated
right after the attack was not
consistent with that expected from a
chemical attack according to doctors
there some doctors had never even heard
of the events shown in the video yet
another bit of proof that the initial
video from the hospital could have been
a hoax after almost six months of
investigations
I can prove without a doubt that the
duma hospital scene was staged no
fatalities are
occurred in the hospital that was a BBC
producer for you an employee of a
channel there was among those happy to
use the video as the real thing to cover
the story disturbing reports of a
chemical weapons attack chemical attack
carried out by the Assad regime the
Maddox are doing what they can but
they're overwhelmed dozens of people
have been killed due to poison gas
almost a year since the attack still no
definitive proof to tie the Syrian
government to it but who cares anyway
the sentence had already been delivered
and carried out by the US and its allies
missiles
you